foreign
[Music]
so uh you're a fan of the Patriots
aren't you [ __ ] you
I hate the New England Patriots what
about the Buccaneers
all right okay do you like rich
hornberger
who's that who's that he's on the
Patriots who's linebacker dude hackers
hello hornbacher hornbacher I love their
cookies
I don't know all right so uh oh orange
yeah back when Rich orenberger was uh
was playing for the Patriots as
linebacker uh he woke up late for
practice I heard about this when this
happens like the coach is gonna [ __ ]
cut you so in order to avoid that he uh
basically had five minutes to get 15
minutes to the practice there's no way
he was gonna make it so he intentionally
crashed his car in order to have an
excuse he crashed into another person he
sees a human no another person's vehicle
Oh I thought he was ran someone over
dude
that's a good excuse I'm really gonna
have an excuse me
did a little bump she's like a church
band with like one it
and then uh yeah he pays the guy for
like the damage and everything like he
had his whole like [ __ ] planned out and
then he was able to go to practice with
that story and he didn't get cut that's
tight how did the truth come yeah he's
later he talked about it on podcast very
recently he talked about it on his
podcast oh because he doesn't play for
the Patriots anymore but oh he's okay
you got it but now he's revealing how he
[ __ ] crazy situation got the
[ __ ] yeah exactly he was so
[ __ ] terrified about chicken yeah
yeah what is what would happen yeah I
don't know much you guys know who Jonas
Gray is no Jonas Gray is is he had one
of the most amazing games I've ever seen
and I know because he was against the
cult so it was [ __ ] really sucked
actually he he was a running back and he
scored five touchdowns in one game wow
which is crazy nobody ever heard of him
in their [ __ ] Al Bundy did oh
that's right no ma'am no man oh man
nobody ever heard of Jonas Gray in their
whole [ __ ] lives and all of a sudden
he comes out of nowhere he scores five
touchdowns against the Colts we had a
horrible run defense all that [ __ ] but
still credit to Jonas Gray right so then
all of a sudden Sports Illustrated has
Jonas Gray on the cover like everyone's
talking about Jonas Gray and like holy
[ __ ] this like this is the next big
running back and all this [ __ ] so the
next week he shows up late to practice
and then Bill Belichick is like hey take
a seat on the bench they run practice
without him right then they go for the
next game they make it they bench them
the whole [ __ ] time
they bench them for the rest of the year
he gets cut at the end of the season
nobody's ever [ __ ] heard of him again
just because he was late because he was
late to practice that's how hardcore it
is Bill Belichick is hard and that's
like throwing away like literally
millions of dollars yeah absolutely for
him and he's probably like cost benefit
analysis crash into this car pay a
couple G's or lose my [ __ ] seven
eight figure shout out to that guy that
guy that's it and now I get it now I get
it do you agree do I agree with that
[ __ ] no that's [ __ ] crazy yeah what
do you mean like you don't agree with
Bill doing doing that benching that dude
dude I'm not one the greatest coach of
all time
Bill Belichick came up like his father's
military right so oh okay he learned
like from watching all that and his dad
had a particular way I think of of
disciplining the game and I think that
he carried that into it because you know
what this is this is our version of I
can't come to work right now I'm sick
like people always got a fake cop in the
middle of the conversation he was like
I'm crashing my car nobody does that
[ __ ] at this office
what kind of car was it it was like uh
what is an old vans like a church van
you know no no what was his car oh he
didn't say he didn't say we probably had
a nice one because I'm yeah he's like
yeah if I had a nice car it was one of
those Dodge ones with the big like
Korean writing on the side with
Methodist church I saw this one
interview with the um with the Korean
Jesus yeah I saw this one interview with
like a uh I forgot which I don't really
watch football but he's like I guess
like a highly regarded football coach
and they asked them like hey during that
one draft how come you had the the the
option to pick the number one draft pick
but you picked number 30. why did why
did you make that decision was it Tony
Dungy I forgot but he said number one he
goes yeah he's really really good but he
goes but off the field Behavior he
really likes to party so he'll party
every single night and the problem with
that is he has the genetics and the
capability to party and play his [ __ ]
ass off tomorrow the big problem is he
takes one through eight with him to the
party and somebody does that even though
you have the best player on the team he
like trashes the team he goes this
number 30 guy he's the guy that I know
that I guess he's probably like the hall
monitor of the group but he's like no
one parties with him around and so he he
brings up the entire team so he's like
that's why I picked him and it was such
a like I guess like a mind-blowing
moment to people yeah it's like
Moneyball 30 over a number dude that
makes a lot of sense because think about
it that talented player has all the
influence right so you're like I'm a
robot dude other [ __ ] think
they're probably aligned with him so
they're like yeah I'll go party like
Michael Jordan's partying he's like yeah
but he probably can't Jordan yeah right
he didn't though no he didn't yeah oh no
he didn't kept playing that's right he
did it he kept practicing but that's the
thing that's why locker room is such a
thing that's what the locker room
mentality is such a thing that they
always talk about that yeah but what's
locker room because I you know we didn't
have that in cheerleading yeah were you
like the only one in the locker room and
then the other they had the locker room
and they're like I had my own locker
room by myself it's like GI Jane and
[ __ ] you have your own space all lonely
just sitting here
what locker room mentality and the
coaches watching the shower that's like
GI Jane yeah but that's you know such a
weird scene it's my favorite scene she's
like showering and he's like
you know they're gonna kill you out here
I don't get [ __ ]
it wasn't a locker room he's the best
coach of all time there's no I don't
think in football there's any question
about it he's the greatest he's the
greatest NFL coach and apparently how he
got to start was crazy too like he was
just like an assistant or something yeah
he was assistant coach at for the well
God he's done so much he's so Giants
Browns so he did little league first and
then went his way up worked his way up
apparently he's doing military
he's like oh literally I can't remember
his dad was army or navy but he was he
was working there too but they would say
like he was a notorious for studying
film because nobody wanted to do that
kind of job but he was the only one that
did that and he did it to the very like
he studied old plays not even old plays
but just like he was watching so he
would his his brain for football is on
another level that that most people
can't really keep up because he's done
all the hard work and he don't even like
even when they try to ask him like like
dramatic questions and [ __ ] he won't
even answer this but you can ask him
about a long Snappers play from like the
70s and he'll [ __ ] remember the play
it's weird really so he's pretty
autistic but a lot of those guys are
like high level coaches they have that
same type of like brain and their
knowledge for old history of the sport
is like very vast there's a reference
for it yeah like they love it damn yeah
that's what I heard about Jordan too
actually are you called year game and
he'll tell you like oh that only
happened because this person passed it
to this person and the other person was
like two feet away from the line so they
knew they could make that happen like he
he has like that almost like that's like
me with cheerleading really it's like
when they go like this like uh that
pyramid
kind of lean to the left a little bit
you guys you guys know that Bill
Belichick was the coach for the Jets for
one day right one day one day what
happened what happened so yeah so so he
um he was the head coach for the Jets
um and then Bill Parcells who was like
his mentor he comes into the Jets
organization after saying he was going
to step down he comes in the Jets
organization and he's like I'm going to
be like the GM above you isn't this
great news and Bill Bill Belichick's
like nah [ __ ] this [ __ ] like I resigned
as the head coach of the Jets he put it
on a napkin I resign and then yeah he
gives a [ __ ] beast right and then the
Jets traded him to the Patriots for a
first round pick and that's why Bill
Belichick is the head coach of the
Patriots wow yeah and he's been the head
coach for how long
it's like 90 2 000 I think or 99 or 2000
don't teams have uh multiple coaches
well yeah there's a head coach and then
there's a system so like the head is
like the CEO or whatever and then he has
like right hand coordinators and
offensive coach defensive coach yeah but
Bill Belichick is the defensive
coordinator for the Patriots and you
know he he
there's a lot of talk about how it works
with them but nobody exactly knows also
different teams have different methods
of how coaches run what well yeah but
but Bill Belichick so like there's a guy
named Matt Patricia who was the Patriots
defensive coordinator and then everybody
poached him remember going to the Lions
I think and then he went to uh well they
sucked and then and then everyone's like
whoa the Patriots defense is still so
[ __ ] good and everyone's like yeah
it's Belichick it's not it's not them
it's Bellow gem oh okay so why is your
favorite team the Eagles
he's been doing this to me for two days
for some reason
[Laughter]
yeah why he's already in pain
or something dude Niners fans are
honestly the worst [ __ ] human beings
on the planet not Raiders wait so who's
your team Colts okay okay have you ever
watched a game with Niners fans I
thought the Raiders were the worst
because they'll stab you oh yeah well
yeah but Raider spins the worst Raiders
fans don't even watch the Raiders yeah
watch he's gonna kick they're just
they're just rapping try watching a game
with Niners fans honestly even some nice
fans might even agree with me on this
take okay because like Niners fans are
[ __ ] obnoxious oh no that's why
they're just socially like obnoxious why
I mean they're from San Francisco are
they like Giants fans like uh San
Francisco Giants fans because people say
that about the Giants like the baseball
team oh I don't know this much maybe San
Francisco fans are just mean maybe
that's weird because I mean like
everyone's nice I know that's what I'm
saying I don't think a lot of the fans
are from San Fran though they're from
like [ __ ]
shut up dude take it back yeah I'm not a
Niner fan like San Bernardino Pasadena
they're all not all Niners fans are from
Pasadena that's the biggest thing
looks like our fan base is from Hemet
[Music]